president-elect joe biden and vice
president-elect kamala harris also plan
to go to georgia soon
but it is not their only priority before
their january
20th inauguration the transition team
says mr biden
will be sworn in and dismisses
republican threats to block his victory
next week
as quote antics nicole killian is
covering the president-elect from
rehoboth beach delaware this morning
nicole good morning when will we see the
president-elect head to the peach
state good morning to you dana the
president-elect is spending the new
year's weekend
here in rehoboth beach then he'll go
down to georgia on monday the vice
president-elect travels there
tomorrow it'll be the second trip for
both of them in a sign
they're not taking any vote for granted
i'm more optimistic about america's
chances than i've ever been
in their last interview before the new
year president-elect joe biden and his
wife jill
hopeful and mindful of the task ahead
we've now found vaccines that are
available
and they're going to work if people we
can just have to get a better way to get
him more out there
quicker i find that we're in a situation
where we once again have to step
up and lead the world and lead the
nation with the covid death toll
steadily rising
the president-elect plans to honor the
more than 300 thousand lives lost in a
nationwide tribute on the eve of his
inauguration
which is expected to be a smaller more
subdued celebration
he has pledged to ramp up vaccine
distribution
testing and reopened schools within the
first 100 days of his administration
most of his team is complete but he
still has a handful of key vacancies to
fill
including labor secretary commerce and
attorney general
which could be announced next week i
will say that he is very thoughtful
about how he makes the decisions of who
he's going to nominate for the cabinet
and any real personnel decisions and
we believe he deserves the time and
space but patience
is wearing thin between mr biden and the
trump administration
white house budget director russ vaught
recently accused the transition a false
statement
after it alleged a lack of cooperation
could lead to budget delays this year
a transition spokesperson said in a
statement it is
indefensible to hamstring the united
states government's ability to prepare a
budget
and efficiently deliver help to those
who need it most
the president-elect has also said his
team is not getting what it needs from
the defense department which paused
meetings over the holiday the pentagon
says that pause was mutually agreed to
the transition
says it wasn't either way they're set to
resume next week
tarika all right a lot of back and forth
thank you nicole